[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys well we are
currently off the record hey we're
wrecked boys today huh hey
that should be our first of merch yeah
right boys
you know what i love is that when the
whole luna [ __ ] came we're talking about
[ __ ] tara luna guys we're finally
gonna do let's go when that
[ __ ] thing came on okay so
steve isn't here every [ __ ] week
right um i no i was hiding
that's exactly my point here i didn't
want to face it simply in fear he didn't
want to come out and tell nobody
no i bro your excuse is because you're
supposed to [ __ ] be here dude yeah i
was in mexico for a wedding and i told
you guys months prior that it sounds
like [ __ ] you were hiding hiding
good we were all hiding so so i blame
bart
because uh i think um he he forgot that
but that week it was um it was it just
so happened that it was just us and i
was like man we can't have a [ __ ]
tara luna [ __ ] off the record without
stephen anthony here like all good bro
you know and then i was like but you
know what we still gotta do it yeah of
course so we did it with eric because
eric is great he knows a lot about
crypto he actually broke it down very
fairly and what in a way that people
could digest if they had no idea about
crypto and i think that's why i like
eric a lot he's great i learned a lot
from that but i think what people really
wanted to know is not tara luna the news
because they could get that anywhere
they wanted to know what the [ __ ]
happened at that moment from you guys
because i told my story yeah they want
to know what happened to steve they
don't know how deep i was in it i think
oh they knew they were talking i don't
think they do though no people don't
know people don't know but
but uh so the real thing for me well
it's a couple things i've been crypto
since 2013 so and i've been wrecking
crypto before i admit i've turned a very
small amount of money into a million
dollars twice
uh and then lost it all
so i'll just have to do it again twice
but but third time's a charm three times
the charm you know but but no really
honestly the the thing about this stuff
for me
is like i love the space so like the
idea that like i'm gonna get
discouraged by like what happened to
luna and just blame
you know all blockchain and go like oh
[ __ ] crypto or anything that's never
gonna be in the cards for me i love this
stuff and actually you were actually
amazing my friend um he texts me day of
when all this is going down and he's
like i know
he's like i know you he's like i know
what you're doing right now he's like
you're sitting there and you're working
on the next thing and this is before by
the way i even got i even got to really
talk about any of this stuff because
i've talked about this on i mean nikki's
podcast and stuff but like you were you
were letting me know you're like dude
like this was an attack on on ust and on
luna and he's like i know that what
you're doing right now is um
is going to work which i really
appreciate it by the way i really
appreciate that ryan's the best dude
he's a very slept on gym
you know what you know what hannah told
me
i appreciated that she said that all of
our friendships are very strong because
she goes like most people
these this these incidents uh separate
families and friends
there's always someone that brings
someone in to an investment or some idea
they lose money and it just breaks apart
friendships and families constantly and
i'm all like the thing that you do not
know is we've all been through this
already once with steve
and we already told steve you son of a
[ __ ] you made me lose all this money
and then we did it again i got it out of
your system we got it out of our system
that's the meanwhile we still we just
don't have other friends so we're kind
of stuck we're stuck with who we are
stuck
but that's the meme right it's like
everyone thinks it's like you guys are
looking at me and going [ __ ] you or
whatever and it's like dude if anything
i mean well look it was a ride right it
was a ride and we
you know you de-risked id risk which
means i pulled out money yeah i
de-risked as well because i was like
dude i've been through this [ __ ] before
and when putin started shooting guns off
i was like i gotta get some of this [ __ ]
out so i sold like 2000 luna in february
because i was just too
scared of the macro right the macro
environment but man i wish i did more
right that's that's always gonna hit you
a little bit in the back of your head
you're gonna be like man i wish i i wish
i'd de-risk way more that would've been
sick
but the but the real reason why i'm into
crypto is the movement i love what it
does right what it says you can't just
print your money into oblivion you can't
[ __ ] over people who are at the bottom
of the chain because
you know you want to over print the
money supply like zimbabwe or like
what's happening in the united states
right now like you know but
here it's a little bit different though
too because they're printing so much
[ __ ] money and they're hanging out
the wall street and then most of the
people at home get nothing and where
they should have gotten at least 23 000
each if they just took all that money
gave it to the people it would have been
very beneficial to all of us while they
[ __ ] the economy over later with
inflation but instead they give you a
paltry sum they bail out all these
places it's 2000 all over again but so
that's what frustrated me got me into
crypto initially anyway so the movement
doesn't change right the fight goes on
but it sucks because luna was like
[ __ ] dude we were so slept on the
whole run
and then now everyone is talking about
luna everyone your grandma knows the
news went beyond like when luna had
success it was the highest uh margin
like jump in in crypto of 2021 even
close yeah not even close yeah so so it
had the highest uh i guess like like
gainer gain yeah
but
that news didn't even get close to the
news that we got when it absolutely
tanked then i guess like the founder doe
quan his twitter following just went
[ __ ] crazy everyone was talking about
luna i'm just like it's crazy how like
when something catastrophic happens it
just gets so much publicity yeah but
then when something does well it doesn't
get as much
yeah and that's really the story for us
too like because we
insane ride insane ride like buying at
five
buying at five and six
see watching it go to 100 yeah oh crazy
crazy and then the way they were gonna
back ust with bitcoin because they knew
there was like a shortfall where like
there was so much um market cap now
worth of ust i don't know if you guys
know what ust is but like it was a
stable coin the idea of it was an
algorithmic stable coin so it's always
going to be worth 100 pennies or one
dollar so it's like the idea of it is
for every one dollar of ust that you
generate one dollar of luna gets burned
so
as more protocols um come on to luna all
these different you know
great dev teams so everyone likes to say
oh lunas is ponzi game all this stuff
all this stuff but they don't understand
what was actually going on with them
like you're talking about dev teams who
are building out
different protocols for luna and then
everyone looks at anchor protocol and
they go see it was 20
fixed for ust which is a stable coin
that was never going to last and anchor
protocol was the first p first group to
tell you that wasn't going to last it
was a promotional period they were they
were loading money into that fund to
keep the 20 percent but the idea
of it was a temporary ponzi but
but the idea of it was was to be to
fluctuate based on demand so it was
going to go down and they even predicted
it would go like 14 or something which
they got the funding from the
transactions and yeah every transaction
on network right that went through and
then people who were staking yeah it's
not a sexy story as a ponzi scheme it's
not but i think the way that if you
understand if you could look at crypto
it's like anchor protocol was just one
of many like it's like it's like blaming
ethereum because someone designed
something on the ethereum network that
was shady you can't blame all of
ethereum for that but um
aside from that i think like the juicy
story here though is like the personal
um experience of what you guys went
through during those moments
so like
i know what happened on my end i had a
oh [ __ ] moment
i was probably jacking off or something
okay i wasn't there your free ball
beating it right
was your dick all the way out yeah was
your pants down i think i came to my
senses after i busted a nut and i said
oh no i got to get my money out no no i
think um steve here
was helping me on the phone
while you're jacking off yes and then
getting my money out i was like you
better [ __ ] come now little man
and i was like j-o-y and i said you have
10 minutes 10 minutes to come is that
j-o-y jack-off instructions you have ten
minutes to come and then or otherwise
you're never gonna he was also helping
me move one one phone for some reason
yeah i didn't know how to do the money
because i didn't use whatever it was but
during this whole time i was like i
didn't realize that you
you had all your money locked up at that
time so i was just like wait once i
noticed i was like oh [ __ ] i thought you
just
de-risked it right now yeah yeah yeah
well that's because i sounded like i do
right now but that's
you know because i've de-risked in
february i wasn't just totally
obliterated right like thank god right
but but man there were so many who did
so i'm trying to you know you you try to
feel for that like dude literally people
some people took their lives like it's
crazy what happened that's what yeah i
went live too suicides that were like
oh my god doing the suicide science and
i was i was one of those people that
didn't have my stuff de-risked so i
pretty much lost everything
um and it was crazy because i had many
of y'all texting me too and even like
close friends that i also got into luna
and stuff they're hitting me up they're
like yo i heard like people were like
killing themselves and [ __ ] like this is
crazy like are you okay so i
maybe i got more dramatic because i had
also gone through you know 2017 2018 and
lost the [ __ ] ton then too so like i
think maybe you're when you're used to
seeing your kind of digital bank account
go from like zero to this and then go
from this to zero it's you're less
you're desensitized a little bit even
though it's still [ __ ] is painful but
when your friends start texting you're
like yo are you okay and you have to
start trying to explain stuff it
actually kind of adds a little bit more
um reality to it it kind of makes it a
little bit more real so i'm not blaming
my friends or saying that it was tough
or anything but it painted more of a
picture on like how crazy the situation
was because people were for real
committing suicide yeah imagine how many
people were like you know selling or
taking loans or quitting their jobs or
like whatever it is in order to put
everything into luna and once you lose
it all it's a tough thing to stomach you
know this is this is what i was thinking
too it's like
yeah it hurt but then i have survivors
guilt because i got away with money like
which like like you didn't like and then
another thing is like um we all have
earning potential like meaning like if
we wanted to we can figure out a way to
earn five figures six figures whatever
right
but there's people that we knew who had
just like 12 an hour job or whatever
and so the type of like let's say they
lose a hundred thousand dollars
to get that back
it's life-changing money for them and
that's where i felt like extremely bad
for them because i was like
[ __ ] well unless you figure out another
job
choice or a different way to get income
that's going to take you forever to
bring that stack back up
or like but if you're at the mercy of
the trend right like the market you have
to wait and that's where we're at right
now you just have to accumulate but it's
the earning to potential is different so
like if you can do something to get
a bunch of money and then you can buy
more crypto you're back in the game yeah
but if you're like you know kind of
stuck at if you're not emotionally
wrecked though no the mindset's
everything yeah the mindset's everything
because we're all going back in oh
because this is just like a battle that
you learned yeah yeah it's not over this
is a setback but that's because we've
seen it before but there's a lot of
people who probably came in for the
first time you know and even if they
didn't lose like a million dollars like
most of us maybe they only lost like
twenty thousand but that was the first
time they ever lost twenty thousand
dollars yeah that's a lot of money
today's video is brought to you by tushy
now imagine you're walking down the
street okay you're like on a date you're
having a great time
you're talking to this girl right and a
bird dookie's all over your arm there's
cocker just bird pigeon cocker all over
your arm right what do you do you get
her jacket and [ __ ] wipe it off maybe
you know maybe you grab her hat wipe it
off or maybe you're a gentleman you take
off your t-shirt because you got a nice
set of abs and you wipe it off right but
do you still feel
magically clean do you want to cuddle
with her after no because you got dookie
all over your arm you're probably going
to be like
mad moiselle madame as well
because you're in french or whatever i i
got to go to the park bathroom or water
fountain
kick the kids off be like get out of
here kid and then you freaking why you
wash off the bird dookie right
you don't just wipe it
that's like what that's that's just
caveman [ __ ]
now we do this every day millions of
people all over the world they do not
know that they're doing this to
themselves because after they go number
two what do they do they just get paper
and smear that bajo with toilet paper
now this is what tushy is trying to
solve today and they're doing a damn
good job at it
the tushy is a wonderful contraption you
can spray your butt clean it it's like a
shower and then you can dab that toilet
paper right there and be done with it
and you feel fresh you feel like you
just took a shower but in between the
cheeks it's wonderful i use it all the
time and it's super easy to install it
takes eight minutes to do this and not
only that you save about eighty percent
in tp usage so you save a lot of money
too
it practically just pays for itself i
want all of our listeners to have clean
bums visit hellotushi hellotushi.com
off the record to get 10 off and free
shipping right now tag us and at us at
hellotushy on all social media so we can
share and celebrate your clean butt with
you that's
hellotushy.com off the record for ten
percent off more than five thousand is
big so so yeah it's dude it's it's it's
a thing right but but the the thing
about this stuff for me personally is
just what it does like if you are in a
third world country
and um you want to get a td amount of
trade account you you feel like you've
been reading about the united states
stock market and you want to participate
where the land in the land of the free
you can hold in in your funds into a
401k and retire at a certain age because
of the growth of all these companies
like if you zoom out enough so you do
the work you want to participate you
can't you live in a place where they
don't allow you to through decentralized
finance you can you can use all kinds of
different access um access points
through defy and so that's what i love
about this stuff so the love never
changes the fact that ust got attacked
and beaten by um an exploit frankly
so far we're seeing that like maybe 20
wallets are responsible
for pulling
a lot of the liquidity for ust like at
one point right just selling ust at the
same time in the same hours what it's
looking like at least seven wallets were
responsible for that
how much money are you talking about
hundreds of millions
yeah the whole the whole goal i think
was to uh pretty much short bitcoin and
sell ufc at the exact same time and
throw it off the path
broadcasted his plan which is you know
what everyone's kind of criticizing is
like hey dude the mechanism didn't exist
yet why did you broadcast the plan if
your plan to sell bitcoin for ust right
so think about like this right if if ust
is supposed to be worth 100 pennies or
one dollar at all times if it slips that
if it goes to 90 cents you're supposed
to be able to take this reserve like
three billion dollars of bitcoin sell
that
into ust restoring that peg right so
you're creating value for usd by buying
it
and then it's supposed to go back up to
where it belongs but unfortunately the
damage was already done they didn't have
enough money to absorb the shock because
there's a 18.5 billion dollar market cap
and you got 3.5 billion dollars so the
ceiling and the floor quite a lot of air
between those two things and that's what
[ __ ] us right so that sucks and
frankly we should de-risk more obviously
that's a very easy thing to sit here and
say in retrospect it's easy yeah it
wasn't even an option like if you told
any of us this to de-risk into
us dollars or anything we would have
laughed
at ourselves this top performing corner
for like over a year even the night dude
even the night that i de-risked which i
told on my crypto corners about i was
like yo i gotta just do this because
uh the way putin's blowing [ __ ] up the
macros are getting weird so i just have
to de-risk something right because i was
i went through
2017-2018 so i gotta i gotta learn
lesson from that right and i was like i
couldn't look at nikki knowing i didn't
de-risk anything from this run but she
was [ __ ] bananas right turned a very
small amount of money into a very big
amount of money did better than last
time even but if i didn't if i don't see
anything for that at this time that will
suck
and then um i told nikki that night
though i was like
it sucks because i feel like i had more
luna i just sold it and i'm i think i'm
selling my future kind of because that's
how
much i really believed in layer one
solution of luna so when you first do
your wrist you were [ __ ] kind of like
i was bummed i was bummed it was a bomb
but and then and then you must have felt
even more [ __ ] when it went back to 100
something absolutely yeah
but and and honestly too
and i love my corners so much and they
are they're both great balls they're the
best they're great and they were busting
my balls they're like man when steve uh
sold the [ __ ] we went back to the
[ __ ] 120 or whatever and i and like
that's all great but taking profits is
always a good thing like always always
always a good thing right
that everything was passion
um i was i was talking to the crypto
corner team and i was like man luna's
cheap right now and i bought 50 grand
worth
and it i i just went to [ __ ]
you just donated basically yeah
basically i saw by 50 grand went to like
20 grand
in a matter of an hour were you watching
holy [ __ ] you know what because usc was
the key to the game for me you know it's
a really [ __ ] up and crazy feeling i'm
just gonna say it here because we're
obviously talking about something so
unique right um everybody was calling a
black swan event it's not just like oh
this project tank these devs suck there
was an x point it was like the exploit
of the entire century for this this is
going to be a [ __ ] thing in the
history yeah this is like literally case
study this is on top this is like some
1929 stock market crash type of
experience for a lot of people obviously
suicides happen right and the [ __ ] up
human experience that i remember like
trying to because it gets
emotionally and mentally when you get
invested in something it's very very
difficult you know what i mean to like
uh separate
your own logic and your own morals in
terms of what you're experiencing when
you're just getting [ __ ] railed by
something that is more big is bigger
than you right and i remember this like
really dark feeling i'm like reading
about people who or like committing
suicide
and yet that made me feel
for lack of better terms better
um because it made me realize that i
wasn't as lost and it was the saddest
feeling i get that thought yeah yeah
that's also sounds guilty yeah so that's
that's what i have i have survivor's
guilt [ __ ] feeling to be like um like
no matter how much i got wrecked i'm
like well i'm
i'm all right people are like you're
right and i'm like i i'm not off in
myself and i'm not even thinking about
offering myself and all these people are
doing that so i think i'm all right you
know what i'm saying it was just so
weird to see any experience to just
participate in that the best way i can
explain it losing a lot of money like
that is like um getting dumped yeah
exactly i felt like i got dumped by
someone i really really liked and like
it was really good and it's almost like
dude i thought we had a great time
like like what happened
like was it me well yeah was it me like
no
but not only did i get dumped i get no
explanation i get ghosted and i'm just
like baby come back and everybody's
talking to you like why didn't you know
i know basically
yeah it's like it was right under your
nose ponzi it's like yeah okay [ __ ] you
totally that's actually the worst once
people come out the woodworks because
they hear all the [ __ ] negative
presence suddenly feel like they have a
stake in the conversation of what you've
invested you're pretty quiet before
actually so just want to keep it down
and there was people there was even
people on twitter that was like tagging
all three of us dude the i told you
songs and there were being dicks about
it and and a part of me somebody
somebody
i obviously didn't respond to a lot of
the tweets but one of the tweets was
like yo you know like do you blame steve
and that's when i felt i had to not clap
back but i had to be like no steve got
me into this and we had a great time we
learned a lot about bond he's a good
friend and i still hang out with him so
i don't know yeah you know what i mean
it's like people need to like four days
later we're buying other
people but that's the thing people think
that like oh we're not friends anymore
it's like so funny the first [ __ ] zoo
meeting i have with steve after all this
crazy stuff is i was like i i guess
should i buy woo now yeah like like
you're like you you told me actually
you're like okay i want to get back in
the game and i'm like let's go
[ __ ] but that's also
what makes me think like nice the people
that speak to us like that they're
[ __ ] weak-minded they don't have
friends like this they just like it's
like that would be their threshold they
would lose friendships they wouldn't be
able to stay in investments like this so
it's like but hey mclean once put it
some people just want to see the world
burn there you go but hey you know what
i can't believe i'm australian i can't
i can't believe either you know why
because when you look at some of this
stuff and you look at like you know
anchor right we're getting we're getting
like between 18.5 20
for like a year plus
in flux
um if we didn't even touch that just
kept that [ __ ] in a savings account
which we were hating on the whole
[ __ ] time i get that argument it's
like oh dude you would have done better
just chilling in the [ __ ] game that
already exists for you i get that so
good for you by the way i i don't
i don't hate on that at all but for me i
only ever risked what i was willing to
lose which for me and nikki various
[ __ ] small amount of money
like we ever we only ever put 18 g's
into crypto i've turned that into a
million dollars twice [ __ ] well 735
first time second time 1.2 so come at me
if you want that's one point i'm going
to do it again
i'm going to do it again and i'm going
to do it better this will at the poker
team dude
that's the other that's the other i
can't brag i put i put 300 grand into it
of my real hard-earned cash
yeah well but but that's the other thing
that i love about this [ __ ] right it's
like you know
dude don't count the greens out for long
because [ __ ] nicki just won i mean
dude she won even before that she won
like 13 or what 12-5
nine days before she won 116. so like
just chill out i mean the once you're in
a to me it's like once you're in the
game right that's the war and then the
war can go on till you retire and you i
mean it's like being a traitor being
anything you go up and down yeah but the
point is if you're constantly going down
then you probably should leave the game
yeah but we go up baby like this is our
second time winning a meal doesn't that
mean we're also it's our second time
losing email so we are technically
almost at constantly going down i would
say you're constantly going to me my
barrier is the uh my base is the
principle so if you're constantly
dipping under that principle and you're
losing money and you've consistently
lost money and you're never going above
that threshold you should probably leave
the game let me put it like this i've
never started a bear market with as much
money as i have now
so [ __ ] with me
gangbusters dude i'm telling you well
but but but it's not because of anything
else honestly i just love this [ __ ] i
love this stuff right i love what it can
do and yes there is so much [ __ ] in
this space just like companies just like
when you're a vc investor i mean that's
the reason why you buy 50 companies
because you know maybe two will work out
right like that's just how it is with
startups that's what we're doing with
crypto we're the mentality is you're
investing in startups and you're looking
for an edge that everyone else is
missing i'm already on the next one i've
been on it for a year and yeah it's gone
down bro let's be real right it's going
down like i was first buying it it was
like [ __ ] 70 cents it's gone down
it's like [ __ ] my my woo baby is it
like got 16 cents tonight
awesome opportunity right another chance
to stack more of something that i
thought was value it's valuable at 70
cents and that's the mentality you have
to have it's not
you know oh no my investment i'm so
emotional this isn't working out [ __ ]
you i'm gonna sell it because i'm so mad
at it no it's like i have an advantage
everyone's missing it
they're gonna catch up when it's
probably near too late and that's why
i'm going to win and probably some
people are going to lose because they're
going to be buying some [ __ ] that
everyone on [ __ ] youtube is already
talking about so it's never going to
really do that well because already
everyone bought the [ __ ] out of it so
like they're buying it way too late and
like that's cool but i'm looking for my
advantage that everyone else is missing
finding a use case that the market needs
and that's going to drive my portfolio
not this [ __ ] like i have a shark
face
and a youtube video and here's my
[ __ ] token like yeah
why cardano is the next best thing
cardano a top five coin will be the next
big thing yeah good luck bro
[Laughter]
are you starting a war in the crypto
community yeah no honestly it's not even
the cryptocurrency agrees with me
starting awards lately
no
no the um the way that people talk about
crypto that's the part that pisses me
off it's like because you can tell when
somebody knows about something and if
you've been in a space long enough you
can tell when somebody doesn't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about but
they're using buzzwords yeah so that's
the difference is like okay cool spot
the market need look for the way that
something is doing something differently
than everyone else it's called value
investing that's it [ __ ] and and i am
doing it again
so watch me that's that's funny because
on the on the ig live that we were doing
a bunch of fans were like how did you
get how did you guys not know like that
uh
that uh luna was a scam and i was i'm
like oh did you know and like yeah until
you can see all the signs did you short
did you bet again yeah no really
honestly yeah if you know if you knew
that much why didn't you [ __ ] short
you would have been a millionaire make
money off the drop if you're so sure it
was gonna happen like nobody knew like
come on it's always easy to say that
after you had a hunch or like you just i
don't know it's confirmation bias that's
all it is but hey credit to them
honestly because it was an exploit luna
was vulnerable through this ust attack
method
honestly and another thing too that
people are missing is that the way that
ust went multi-chain kind of [ __ ] us a
little bit because we didn't have enough
liquidity to cover us
when they were trying to pull
from one place to provide liquidity to
another place where they were going to
plug in this mechanism to allow bitcoin
to back ust
we got [ __ ] wrecked by that disparity
of time
and the lack of that mechanism
having to send bitcoin to an otc desk
right over the counter desk to have them
perform the swap
instead of being able to just do it
mechanically using the platform [ __ ]
us for sure so hey like i said when this
all happened the night that it happened
because i was live on crypto corner as
it was happening
credit to the people good job you beat
us in the short term that's fine but i
will [ __ ] have my revenge dude this
is what i do [ __ ]
i'll be back we all will be back here
it's steve that's
i also love how like this exploit the
amount of money that it took to do it
it's like if you have that much money
you could probably find an exploit in
most things billions bro but that's what
that's but that's what dokuan gets you
know in fairness for saying like because
because a guy a guy in november right he
tweets out and he called him a [ __ ]
how you could attack this [ __ ] a guy
called and dope one calls him a [ __ ]
and then says all my billionaire
followers do it see what happens and
they did the billionaires came ouchies
max algie's yeah they came yeah
so those little oopsie doopsies
by documents but we'll be back
[Music]